Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals, be careful along our tracks, and only make left turns where it's safe to do so. Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. Hello, Tom Holland here. This is just to warn you that this episode contains sexually sensitive content.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，埃格林顿跨城轻轨（Eglinton Crosstown LRT）列车测试正在进行中。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能经过轨道。请务必遵守所有交通信号，在轨道沿线保持谨慎，且仅在安全的情况下进行左转。保持警惕，注意周围环境，确保安全。你好，我是汤姆·霍兰德。此声明旨在提醒您，本集包含性敏感内容。
So please do be warned. But don't necessarily be put off listening to it for that reason. Ancient of days. Augusta, Thena, where, where are thy men of might, thy grand in soul, gone, glimmering through the dream of things that were? First in the race that led to glory's goal, they won and passed away.
所以请务必留意。但不必因此而放弃收听。往昔的岁月。奥古斯塔，雅典娜，你们那些强大的勇士，那些灵魂高尚的人，都去哪儿了？他们消失在往事如梦的幻影中。在通往荣耀终点的赛跑中，他们率先冲线，随后便消逝了。
Is this the whole? A schoolboy's tale. The wonder of an hour. The warrior's weapon and the sophist's stole are sought in vain. And o'er each mouldering tower, dim with the mist of years, grey flits the shade of power. So that is the deathless poetry of Childe Harold's Pilgrimage, which is a poem that Lord Byron began in the autumn of 1809 while he was in Albania. And never, I think, Tom, did he envisage that it would be read
这就是全部吗？一个学童的故事。一小时的奇迹。勇士的武器和诡辩者的长袍，终究是徒劳的追求。在每一座风化的塔楼之上，在岁月的迷雾中显得昏暗，权力的阴影在灰暗中闪烁。这就是《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中不朽的诗句，这是拜伦勋爵于1809年秋天在阿尔巴尼亚时开始创作的一首诗。我想，汤姆，他从未设想过这首诗会被
with such beauty, power, and power as the listeners have just been treated to. No, I'm sure he'd be thrilled. And of course, I've written a novel in which Byron is a vampire and so he's still alive. And so it's a possibility actually. He may be listening to this right now. He may get to hear that, which would be very exciting for him. Wonderful. Worth becoming a member of the living dead for. So yes, so that is from the poem that makes him famous. Yeah.
以听众刚刚听到的那种美感、力量和感染力来朗读。不，我相信他会感到非常激动。当然，我写过一部小说，书中的拜伦是一个吸血鬼，所以他还活着。所以这实际上是有可能的。他现在可能正在听这个节目。他可能会听到这些，这对他来说会非常令人兴奋。太棒了。为了这个，值得成为活死人的一员。所以，是的，这出自那首让他成名的诗。是的。
He's about to go off on his tours. And when he comes back, he will publish this and become a superstar. And Child's Hill Pilgrimage. So a child is a nobleman's son who has not yet won his spurs. It's a kind of archaicism. Right. And it follows the travels of this tormented nobleman who is haunted by the shadow of some nameless crime, fleeing dissipation, embarked on a voyage of
他即将踏上旅程。当他回来时，他将出版这部作品并成为超级巨星。《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中的“恰尔德”（Childe）是指尚未获得骑士头衔的贵族之子。这是一种古语。没错。它讲述了这位饱受折磨的贵族在某种无名罪行的阴影笼罩下，逃避放荡生活，踏上一段
self-discovery, the kind of the archetype of the romantic hero. And he travels from his crumbling stately home through the Mediterranean all the way to Constantinople. And Byron claims in his introduction that it's nothing to do with him, that Harold is just the child of imagination. But of course, I mean, he knows that we know that that's rubbish, that basically Charles Harold's pilgrimage is child Byron's pilgrimage. And in fact, initially he had called child Harold child Byron. So I think as a poem, it's doubly fascinating because Harold is the alter ego of a man who will become, as the result of its publication, the most famous man, first in Britain and then in Europe. But it is also, as that passage that you read suggests, a meditation on history. So there he is pondering
自我发现之旅的故事，这是浪漫主义英雄的原型。他从破败的祖宅出发，穿过地中海，一直到达君士坦丁堡。拜伦在序言中声称这与他无关，哈罗德只是想象的产物。但当然，我的意思是，他知道我们知道那是胡扯，基本上《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》就是“恰尔德·拜伦游记”。事实上，最初他曾把哈罗德称为“恰尔德·拜伦”。所以我认为作为一首诗，它具有双重魅力，因为哈罗德是那个男人的另一个自我，而这个男人在作品出版后，将成为英国乃至欧洲最著名的人。但正如你朗读的那段文字所暗示的那样，它也是对历史的沉思。所以他在那里思考
how Greece was once beautiful and now it's lost to decay. That's become a cliche for us, but Byron is the first really to articulate it. But Charles Harold is also fascinating because he is traveling through a Europe that is at war. The backdrop to this is the Napoleonic Wars. Because we talked about Byron's early years in our first episode. He's this impecunious nobleman. He is shadowed by anxieties about his sexuality and by what he's going to do with his career. And so he decides that he is going to go abroad and the Napoleonic Wars are rumbling. So he's heading into a war zone when he does that. Yes. So the Peninsular War is underway, isn't it, in Portugal and Spain. Britain has been now at war for 16 years against France, off and on.
希腊曾经是多么美丽，而现在却陷入了衰败。这对我们来说已经成了陈词滥调，但拜伦是第一个真正将其表达出来的人。但《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》之所以引人入胜，还因为它是在一个处于战争状态的欧洲旅行。其背景是拿破仑战争。因为我们在第一集中谈到了拜伦的早年生活。他是一个贫困的贵族。他被对自己性取向的焦虑以及对自己职业生涯的迷茫所困扰。于是他决定出国，而拿破仑战争正隆隆作响。所以他这样做时，正走向一个战区。是的。所以半岛战争正在葡萄牙和西班牙进行，不是吗？英国与法国断断续续交战已经16年了。
The stakes are getting higher and higher. It has become a total war. Yeah. One of national survival for Britain. You know, Napoleon's regime will either triumph and dominate Europe or be consumed. Yeah. So this is a different kind of war from the Seven Years' War or one of the previous 18th century wars. And you might think only a madman would say, brilliant, perfect time and place for a holiday. But Byron is that man. Well, I mean, it's a challenge because Byron can't go to France or to Italy,
赌注越来越高。这已经演变成了一场全面战争。是的。一场关乎英国国家生存的战争。你知道，拿破仑的政权要么会获胜并统治欧洲，要么会被摧毁。是的。所以这与七年战争或之前的任何18世纪战争不同。你可能会认为只有疯子才会说：“太棒了，度假的完美时间和地点。”但拜伦就是那样的人。嗯，我的意思是，这是一个挑战，因为拜伦不能去法国或意大利，
which is the kind of the traditional destination for noblemen wanting a gap year. Because as you say, they're setting off at the time when Napoleon's power is at its absolute apogee. And in fact, while they're at sea, so they leave Falmouth in Cornwall on the 2nd of July, 1809. Byron is going with his Cambridge friend, John Cam Hobhouse. But while they are at sea, they're setting sail for Portugal. Napoleon wins a terrible battle against the Austrians, and the Austrians had been in alliance with Britain. Britain is always trying to kind of fracture Napoleon's continental system that is basically keeping them out of Europe, all their goods, but also, of course, as individual travellers. Napoleon defeats that,
那是贵族们想要间隔年时的传统目的地。因为正如你所说，他们出发时，拿破仑的权力正处于绝对的巅峰。事实上，当他们在海上时——他们于1809年7月2日从康沃尔郡的法尔茅斯出发。拜伦是和他的剑桥朋友约翰·卡姆·霍布豪斯一起去的。但当他们在海上，正扬帆前往葡萄牙时，拿破仑在与奥地利人的战斗中取得了可怕的胜利，而奥地利人曾与英国结盟。英国一直试图打破拿破仑的大陆封锁体系，该体系基本上将他们所有的商品挡在欧洲之外，当然，也包括作为个人旅行者的他们。拿破仑击败了这一点，
so it looks as though his power is as secure as ever. But Byron, of course, again, we talked about this in the first episode, I mean, he kind of admires Napoleon. I think that's partly his natural perversity, his desire to strike an independent pose. It's partly his hostility to what he sees as the repressive character of a Tory Britain. But I think above all, it's flamboyant self-identification. Yes. You know, Byron sees himself as a would-be Napoleonic figure. Yeah, as a sort of man who is not self-made, of course, but he's self-invented, I suppose. Yeah.
所以看起来他的权力依然稳固。但拜伦，当然，我们再次在第一集中谈到了这一点，我的意思是，他有点崇拜拿破仑。我认为这部分是因为他天生的反叛心理，他渴望摆出一种独立的姿态。这部分是因为他对他所认为的托利党英国的压抑性格的敌意。但我认为最重要的是，这是一种浮夸的自我认同。是的。你知道，拜伦把自己视为一个潜在的拿破仑式人物。是的，作为一个并非白手起家，而是自我创造的人，我想。是的。
And he thinks Napoleon has triumphed against these pettifogging bureaucrats who are in Britain. Yeah. Oh, he hopes it will triumph. And he sees himself as surrounded by mediocrities and he will soar above them in the same way that Napoleon has. Yeah. And Dominic, I mean, you, I know, would look very askance at a British peer identifying with Napoleon.
他认为拿破仑已经战胜了英国那些琐碎的官僚。是的。哦，他希望它能获胜。他认为自己被平庸之辈包围，他将像拿破仑一样凌驾于他们之上。是的。多米尼克，我的意思是，我知道你会非常鄙视一个认同拿破仑的英国贵族。
I think it's contemptible, Tom. But some reassurance, because you've just been finishing your new children's book, haven't you, on Nelson? Yeah. Byron does actually admire Nelson, you'll be relieved to hear. Oh, it's not all bad. I think possibly not least because it is thanks to Nelson winning the Battle of Trafalgar and securing the supremacy of the Royal Navy over the seas that Byron is able to travel at all.
汤姆，我觉得这很可鄙。但给你一点安慰，因为你刚刚完成了关于纳尔逊的新童书，不是吗？是的。你会感到欣慰的是，拜伦实际上很崇拜纳尔逊。哦，还不算太糟。我想这可能不仅是因为多亏了纳尔逊赢得了特拉法尔加海战，确保了皇家海军在海上的霸权，拜伦才得以旅行。
Because if the British can't get onto the continent, then the French fleet can't really get onto the seas. And so this means that they can sail in relative security to Portugal. And actually, before he leaves, he has himself painted in a way that deliberately identifies himself with Nelson. So there's a famous portrait of Nelson at the Battle of the Nile being given French colours by a midshipman, kind of a boy. And Byron has himself painted in a kind of similar pose, except that there is a typically Byronic
因为如果英国人不能进入欧洲大陆，那么法国舰队也就无法真正进入海洋。这意味着他们可以相对安全地航行到葡萄牙。事实上，在他离开之前，他让人画了一幅肖像，故意将自己与纳尔逊联系起来。有一幅著名的纳尔逊在尼罗河战役中的肖像，一名见习军官，一个男孩，正把法国旗帜交给他。拜伦让人画了一幅类似的姿势，只是有一个典型的拜伦式
twist, because instead of a midshipman, he has his page boy, Robert Rushton, who is accompanying him on his trip. Very good looking young lad. There's always something a little bit suspicious when Byron is in the room with a young page boy, I would say, isn't it, Tom? And am I not right in saying that he tells, I mean, this is an unbelievable fact. I read he writes to his housemaster at Harrow, his old housemaster, to say he's planning to do a survey of the morals of the Turks, which is a very disturbing suggestion. And then he says, I will write a treatise. Is this right? Do you want to read the title of his treatise? Yeah. The title was going to be Sodomy Simplified, or Pederasty Proved to be Praiseworthy from
转折，因为他没有用见习军官，而是用了他的侍从男孩罗伯特·拉什顿，他正陪同他旅行。非常帅气的年轻小伙子。汤姆，我得说，当拜伦和一个年轻侍从男孩在一起时，总有些可疑之处，不是吗？我没说错吧，他告诉——我的意思是，这是一个令人难以置信的事实。我读到他写信给他在哈罗公学的舍监，他以前的舍监，说他计划对土耳其人的道德进行一项调查，这是一个非常令人不安的建议。然后他说，我将写一篇论文。这是真的吗？你想读一下他论文的标题吗？是的。标题本来是《鸡奸简化论，或从古代作家和现代实践证明鸡奸是值得称赞的》。
Ancient Authors and Modern Practice. And I agree. I mean, imagine writing that to one of your teachers at your school. You know, he left a few years before. I mean, very odd. Anyway, we talked about how essentially this is one of the worst times ever to be gay in Britain. If you are convicted of what is called sodomy, you will very possibly suffer capital punishment. And so you can understand why Byron, who I think has very intense kind of gay longings, why he should feel so liberated to be gone. So he writes exultantly to a friend, the world is all before me and I leave England without regret. But Tom, can I ask you a question?
我同意。我的意思是，想象一下写信给你的学校老师。你知道，他几年前才离开。我的意思是，非常奇怪。无论如何，我们谈到了这基本上是英国历史上对同性恋者最糟糕的时期之一。如果你被判犯有所谓的鸡奸罪，你很可能会遭受死刑。所以你可以理解为什么拜伦，我认为他有非常强烈的同性渴望，为什么他会感到离开这里是如此的解放。所以他兴高采烈地写信给朋友：“世界就在我面前，我离开英国时毫无遗憾。”但汤姆，我可以问你一个问题吗？
Sodom is simplified, okay, fine, he's gay. But pederasty proved to be praiseworthy from ancient authors and modern practice. So ancient authors, pederasty, Byron has already really invested in the idea that same-sex relationships between men and boys. This is even before he goes to Greece. He's going there to find it, right? He thinks Greece is the home and he's already got a taste for it. And how common is that in the time that he's writing? a taste for it. And how common is that in the time that he's writing? Because obviously it's the thing that we associate with the later Victorians, but in the Regency period, are there people who are saying, oh, the Greeks loved all this kind
《鸡奸简化论》，好吧，没问题，他是同性恋。但“从古代作家和现代实践证明鸡奸是值得称赞的”。所以古代作家，鸡奸，拜伦已经真正投入到男人和男孩之间存在同性关系的观念中了。这甚至在他去希腊之前。他去那里是为了寻找它，对吧？他认为希腊是发源地，而且他已经有了这种嗜好。在他写作的那个时代，这有多普遍？因为显然这是我们与后来的维多利亚时代联系在一起的事情，但在摄政时期，有没有人说，哦，希腊人喜欢所有这些
of carry on. It's brilliant. We should do it more often. I think that it is part of the kind of sophisticated gay underworld of upper class people who are steeped in classics and who adopt it as a kind of precursor for their own desires. And I think that Byron is very interested in the Orient and therefore has read about sexual codes in, say, the Ottoman Empire, where it is a given that both women and boys are legitimate objects of sexual predation for powerful men. And that in fact, boys are easier to get than women who tend to be locked up and more inaccessible. Byron, over the course of his travels, will be a great cultural relativist and he will repeatedly compare the sexual taboos that operate in Britain and operate in the Ottoman Empire and kind of adopt the pose of saying,
胡闹。太棒了。我们应该多做几次。我认为这是上层社会中复杂的同性恋地下世界的一部分，他们沉浸在古典文学中，并将其作为他们自己欲望的先驱。我认为拜伦对东方非常感兴趣，因此读过关于性准则的书，比如在奥斯曼帝国，女性和男孩都被视为强大男性的合法性掠夺对象，这是一个既定事实。事实上，男孩比女性更容易得到，因为女性往往被锁起来，更难以接近。拜伦在旅行过程中，将成为一个伟大的文化相对论者，他会反复比较在英国和奥斯曼帝国运作的性禁忌，并摆出一种姿态说，
well, they're both equally the product of their cultures. Why should it be wrong to sleep with a young boy? It's just what they do in their culture. And that is a kind of anthropological perspective that is clearly sharpened by his own personal tastes. I think it's fair to say. anthropological perspective that is clearly sharpened by his own personal tastes yeah i think it's fair to say but you can see why yeah greece and the empire of the turks would be an object of fascination too and he's also he's been dressing up in oriental garb hasn't he before
嗯，它们都是各自文化的产物。为什么和年轻男孩睡觉是错的？这只是他们文化中的做法。这是一种人类学视角，显然被他个人的品味所强化。我认为可以这么说。人类学视角，显然被他个人的品味所强化，是的，我想可以这么说。但你可以看出为什么希腊和土耳其帝国会成为迷恋的对象。而且他之前也一直在穿东方服装，不是吗？
this yeah he loves all that so he's massively into this idea of i mean edward say in his famous book orientalism you know, argued that Westerners objected for the East, they projected onto it all this sensuality and all that kind of thing. And Byron is a perfect example of that, isn't he? Yeah. But for Byron, it's liberating. It's exciting. It's an escape from the kind of monochrome repression that he's come to identify with England. And also I think, I mean, he's come to identify with England. And also, I think, I mean, he's unusual because he is precocious in his anti-imperialism. He does not like militarism. He is opposed to it from the beginning. And of course he is going to Portugal, which is the one place pretty much at this point on the continent where the British can land. Because as you say, the Peninsular War is raging and Portugal,
是的，他喜欢所有这些，所以他非常沉迷于这个想法——我的意思是，爱德华·萨义德在他著名的书《东方主义》中认为，西方人反对东方，他们将所有的感官享受和诸如此类的东西投射到它身上。而拜伦就是一个完美的例子，不是吗？是的。但对拜伦来说，这是解放。这是令人兴奋的，这是对他所认同的英国那种单调压抑的一种逃避。而且我也认为，我的意思是，他很不寻常，因为他在反帝国主义方面早熟。他不喜欢军国主义。他从一开始就反对它。当然，他要去葡萄牙，这是目前欧洲大陆上英国人几乎唯一可以登陆的地方。因为正如你所说，半岛战争正在肆虐，而葡萄牙，
our oldest ally, is in alliance with Britain. And as he lands, Sir Arthur Wellesley, the future Duke of Wellington, he'd arrived in Lisbon only a few months before. He's won a great battle. And as Byron and Hobhouse are travelling from Lisbon towards Seville and then to Gibraltar, Wellesley is preparing for another battle, which will be fought on the 27th and 28th of July at Talavera, and it will be another great victory. But Byron is not impressed by this, partly, I think, because he sees Wellesley as a non-entity compared to Napoleon. But it's also, I think, due to a broader distaste for what he sees of the character of industrial warfare.
我们最古老的盟友，正与英国结盟。当他登陆时，阿瑟·韦尔斯利爵士，未来的威灵顿公爵，他几个月前才抵达里斯本。他赢得了一场伟大的战斗。当拜伦和霍布豪斯从里斯本前往塞维利亚，然后前往直布罗陀时，韦尔斯利正在准备另一场战斗，这场战斗将于7月27日和28日在塔拉韦拉进行，这将是另一场伟大的胜利。但拜伦对此印象不深，部分原因我认为是他认为韦尔斯利与拿破仑相比是个无名小卒。但我也认为，这是由于对他所看到的工业战争的本质有一种更广泛的厌恶。
And this is despite the fact that he loves dressing up as a staff officer. He loves the uniforms. He loves all that. But when they're on their journeys, they kind of witness. So they pass French soldiers and Spaniards who've been accused of treachery being taken off to be hanged. Byron and Childe Harold writes about their journey through the Sierra Morena. At every turn, Morena's dusky height sustains aloft the battery's iron load, and far as mortal eye can compass sight, the mountain howitzer, the broken road, the
尽管他喜欢打扮成参谋军官。他喜欢制服。他喜欢所有这些。但当他们在旅途中时，他们目睹了。所以他们经过法国士兵和被指控叛国的西班牙人，他们被带去绞死。拜伦在《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中写到了他们穿越莫雷纳山脉的旅程。在每一个转弯处，莫雷纳昏暗的高地支撑着炮台的铁负荷，凡人肉眼所及之处，山地榴弹炮，破碎的道路，
bristling palisade, the fossa flowed. So Benita Reisler, who, like Fiona McCarthy, author of two brilliant recent biographies of Byron, she says of this, without ever having seen a battle, Byron became the first major poet of modern warfare. And a distaste and an understanding of what modern warfare means is something that shadows Byron's poetry. He will write very, very powerfully about Waterloo, about wars between the Turks and the Russians. He understands long before the first world war poets, what industrial warfare can mean. So a bit like, I mean, this is the point when you get the first great anti-war art. I mean, Goya, for example, Goya's stuff is reflecting the atrocities of the Peninsular War.
竖立的栅栏，沟壑流淌。所以贝尼塔·赖斯勒，像菲奥娜·麦卡锡一样，两位近期拜伦传记的作者，她对此评价说，在从未见过战斗的情况下，拜伦成为了现代战争的第一位伟大诗人。对现代战争意味着什么的厌恶和理解是笼罩在拜伦诗歌中的东西。他将非常、非常有力地描写滑铁卢，描写土耳其人和俄国人之间的战争。他在第一次世界大战的诗人很久之前就理解了工业战争意味着什么。所以有点像，我的意思是，这是你获得第一批伟大反战艺术的时刻。我的意思是，戈雅，例如，戈雅的作品反映了半岛战争的暴行。
Right. So, you know, this isn't all sort of dragoons and flashing sabres. No, absolutely not. This is hideous reprisals and mass executions. And as you say, it does anticipate the horrors of the 20th century. And it's interesting you mentioned Goya because he has a famous painting, doesn't he, of a giant kind of looming up over. And Byron has an almost identical image in Childe Harold of Spain in the shadow of the kind of god of war. Very, very terrifying and gothic.
没错。所以，你知道，这不仅仅是龙骑兵和闪亮的军刀。不，绝对不是。这是可怕的报复和大规模处决。正如你所说，它确实预示了20世纪的恐怖。你提到戈雅很有趣，因为他有一幅著名的画，不是吗，一个巨人笼罩在上方。拜伦在《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中也有一个几乎相同的形象，西班牙处于战争之神的阴影下。非常、非常可怕和哥特式。
So I think they leave Spain with some relief and they sail on via Sardinia to Malta, where he behaves in very Byronic fashion. So he has a fling with a celebrated beauty there, Mrs. Spencer Smith, who is, despite her name, actually the daughter of the Austrian ambassador to Constantinople and had married a Mr. Spencer Smith, whom she had then left, gone to Venice where she had been taken prisoner on Napoleon's personal orders. And she had then escaped by dressing up as a boy, climbing down a rope ladder and going off in a boat. Crikey. We should do a podcast about her. So, I mean, Byron loves all that kind of stuff. He also almost gets in a duel, so gets out of that. They sign up to going to Greece in a
所以我认为他们带着一些解脱离开了西班牙，他们经由撒丁岛航行到马耳他，他在那里表现得非常拜伦式。所以他在那里和一位著名的美女有了一段风流韵事，斯宾塞·史密斯夫人，尽管她的名字如此，实际上她是奥地利驻君士坦丁堡大使的女儿，嫁给了一位斯宾塞·史密斯先生，然后她离开了，去了威尼斯，在那里她被拿破仑的个人命令逮捕。然后她通过打扮成男孩，爬下绳梯，乘船逃走了。天哪。我们应该为她做一期播客。所以，我的意思是，拜伦喜欢所有这些东西。他也差点卷入决斗，所以摆脱了那个。他们报名去希腊，
British brig of war called the Spider, which is guarding a convoy of merchant ships. We mentioned Patrick O'Brien in the first episode. This is very Patrick O'Brien because they're sailing into enemy waters, because they're going up towards the Ionian Islands, which is Cephalonia and Ithaca and Corfu and all that. I mean, these are under French rule and it's all very exciting. So the spider captures a merchant ship and fits it out as a privateer and Byron and Hobhouse and various crew members of the spider get on board this ship, hoist up the Union Jack. They board various boats. They capture a Turkish vessel. There's a battle.
在一艘名为“蜘蛛号”的英国战舰上，它正在护送一支商船队。我们在第一集中提到了帕特里克·奥布莱恩。这非常帕特里克·奥布莱恩，因为他们正驶向敌方水域，因为他们正前往爱奥尼亚群岛，也就是凯法利尼亚岛、伊萨卡岛和科孚岛等等。我的意思是，这些都在法国统治之下，一切都非常令人兴奋。所以“蜘蛛号”捕获了一艘商船，并将其改装为私掠船，拜伦、霍布豪斯和“蜘蛛号”的几名船员登上了这艘船，升起了联合杰克旗。他们登上了几艘船。他们捕获了一艘土耳其船只。发生了一场战斗。
A bullet whistles past Hobhouse's ear. I mean, terribly exciting. Yeah, very Patrick O'Brien. Yeah. And meanwhile, they have caught their first sight of Greece, and they make landing. They kind of sail up the Gulf of Corinth, so the strip of sea between the two halves of Greece. Yeah. They make landing there at patras lots of romantic effusions and
一颗子弹从霍布豪斯的耳边呼啸而过。我的意思是，非常令人兴奋。是的，非常帕特里克·奥布莱恩。是的。与此同时，他们第一次看到了希腊，他们登陆了。他们沿着科林斯湾航行，也就是希腊两半之间的那条海带。是的。他们在帕特雷登陆，有很多浪漫的抒情和
then they get back on and they sail up the northwestern coast of greece towards albania which is where byron really wants to visit and on their way they pass an obscure seaside town called missolonghi oh yes i see it set amid swamps and lagoons. Yeah. And as they do that, all the way, they are conscious of the fact that Greece is a part of the Ottoman Empire. You know, there are minarets of mosques in the kind of the ancient cities. There are Turkish soldiers everywhere with pistols and daggers in their belts. And Greece has basically been a province of the Ottoman Empire since the collapse of the Byzantine Empire.
然后他们又回到了船上，沿着希腊西北海岸向阿尔巴尼亚航行，那是拜伦真正想去的地方。在路上，他们经过了一个默默无闻的海滨小镇，叫米索隆吉。哦，是的，我看到了，它坐落在沼泽和泻湖之中。是的。当他们这样做时，他们一直意识到希腊是奥斯曼帝国的一部分。你知道，在古代城市里有清真寺的尖塔。到处都是腰间别着手枪和匕首的土耳其士兵。希腊基本上自拜占庭帝国崩溃以来一直是奥地利帝国的一个省。
Yeah. You know, the conquest of Constantinople. Parts of it for 400 years by now. Yeah. So it's not a new thing. I mean, the idea of a Greek nationalism, of an independent Hellenic republic, to a lot of people, I suppose, at the time,
是的。你知道，君士坦丁堡的征服。到目前为止，部分地区已经有400年了。是的。所以这不是什么新鲜事。我的意思是，希腊民族主义、独立的希腊共和国的想法，对当时很多人来说，我想
that would have seemed outlandish because all they've ever known is Greece being part of this vast Ottoman super state. But you can see, Charles Harold, and in Byron's comments more generally, why at this period the idea of Greece becoming free would start to emerge as an ideal. Because the idea of liberty, of national liberty, is something that has been very current since the American Revolution and the French Revolution. But also, Byron is classically educated and it appalls him that ancient Greece that had seen off the Persians should now be subject to the Turks. Childe Harold is full of
那看起来会很古怪，因为他们所知道的只是希腊是这个庞大的奥斯曼超级国家的一部分。但你可以看出，《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》以及拜伦更广泛的评论中，为什么在这个时期，希腊变得自由的想法会开始作为一个理想出现。因为自由，民族自由的想法，自美国革命和法国革命以来一直非常流行。但拜伦也受过古典教育，曾经击败波斯人的古希腊现在竟然受制于土耳其人，这让他感到震惊。《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》充满了
kind of so fair Greece, sad relic of departed worth, immortal though no more, they've fallen great. I mean, he's endlessly going on in this kind of way. But Tom, his image of Greece is an image that he's got from books and his own fantasies rather than from any acquaintance with Greece, right? Completely. I mean, he had this image of Greece before he even went to Greece. Yes, he does have this kind of shimmering sense of it in its classical heyday, but he's not naive, and he is also very, very interested in the Islamic world. I mean, he's not just going for ancient Greece. He is also going because he's fascinated by the civilization of the Ottoman Empire. And that's part of the reason why he wants to go to Albania, because Albania is properly obscure. I mean, up until this point,
那种“哦，美丽的希腊，逝去价值的悲伤遗迹，虽已不朽，却不再伟大”。我的意思是，他没完没了地以这种方式进行。但汤姆，他对希腊的形象是他从书本和自己的幻想中得到的，而不是从对希腊的任何了解中得到的，对吧？完全正确。我的意思是，他在去希腊之前就已经有了这个希腊的形象。是的，他在古典全盛时期对它有一种闪烁的感觉，但他并不天真，而且他也非常、非常对伊斯兰世界感兴趣。我的意思是，他不仅仅是为了古希腊而去。他去也是因为他被奥斯曼帝国的文明所吸引。这就是他想去阿尔巴尼亚的部分原因，因为阿尔巴尼亚确实很晦涩。我的意思是，直到这一点，
he's been on shipping lanes of British ships everywhere. He's among people who are kind of part of his world. But going into Albania, this is properly a journey into the unknown. I mean, this must be the least well-known part of Europe in Britain. I mean, A, Britain now, but also particularly Britain in the early 19th century. I mean, most people would not have even been familiar with the word Albania or the idea of an Albania, an Albanian people. They'd have seen it as a part of the Balkans, part of the Ottoman Empire, obscure, mountainous, sort of tribal, backward. These would have been the associations I thought that people would bring to it. Yeah. And potentially very dangerous because it's, although formerly part of the Ottoman Empire, it's effectively a
他一直都在英国船只的航线上。他身处那些属于他世界的人中间。但进入阿尔巴尼亚，这确实是一次进入未知的旅程。我的意思是，这一定是英国最不为人知的欧洲部分。我的意思是，A，现在的英国，但也特别是在19世纪初的英国。我的意思是，大多数人甚至不会熟悉“阿尔巴尼亚”这个词或阿尔巴尼亚、阿尔巴尼亚人的概念。他们会把它看作巴尔干半岛的一部分，奥斯曼帝国的一部分，晦涩、多山、某种部落、落后。我想这些是人们会联想到的。是的。而且可能非常危险，因为虽然名义上是奥斯曼帝国的一部分，但它实际上是
kind of independent fiefdom under a former bandit chieftain by the name of Ali Pasha, who has been given the kind of the title Vizier of the Three Tales by the Sultan in Constantinople, but effectively rules as a despot. And of course, the French and the British who are engaged in this titanic global conflict are both wooing him. And fortunately for Byron, when they go into Albania, Ali Pasha is pro-British. And so therefore he is going to be very welcoming to a British peer. So Byron is kind of banking on that. But when they get there, Byron adores it right away. Hobhouse and Byron's servant Fletcher, who's come all the way from Newstead, hate it.
一个由前土匪首领阿里帕夏统治的独立封地，他被君士坦丁堡的苏丹授予了“三尾帕夏”的头衔，但实际上是作为暴君统治。当然，卷入这场泰坦尼克式全球冲突的法国人和英国人都在争取他。幸运的是，对于拜伦来说，当他们进入阿尔巴尼亚时，阿里帕夏是亲英的。所以他会对一位英国贵族非常欢迎。所以拜伦有点指望这一点。但当他们到达那里时，拜伦立刻就爱上了它。霍布豪斯和拜伦的仆人弗莱彻，从纽斯特德一路跟来，讨厌它。
You know, the food, the flies, the plumbing, endless complaints about the toilets. You know, you have to kind of squat rather than sit. So when you say they get there. So Ali Pasha's most famous capital is a place called Yanina, which is now in Greece. And it's kind of a citadel on a lake. But he also has a base in what's now Albania. Yeah, Tepelan. Yeah. Which is where he is. So they go to Yanina and then they go to Tepelan.
你知道，食物、苍蝇、管道，没完没了地抱怨厕所。你知道，你必须蹲着而不是坐着。所以当你提到他们到达那里时。所以阿里帕夏最著名的首都是一个叫亚尼纳的地方，现在在希腊。它有点像湖上的城堡。但他也有一个基地在现在的阿尔巴尼亚。是的，特佩伦。是的。他在那里。所以他们去了亚尼纳，然后去了特佩伦。
So they are going through these kind of, what, they're on donkeys, mountain gorges, kind of peasant guides. All of that. Yeah. Eagles, wolves. Right. So as well as being a great poet, Byron is one of the great letter writers in English. And he writes this account of arriving in Tepelein to his mother. I'll read it in focus. It's really wonderful. The Albanians in their
所以他们正穿过这些，什么，他们骑着驴，山峡，某种农民向导。所有这些。是的。老鹰，狼。没错。所以除了是一位伟大的诗人，拜伦还是英语中最伟大的书信作家之一。他写了这篇关于抵达特佩伦的叙述给他的母亲。我会在重点中读它。这真的很棒。阿尔巴尼亚人穿着
dresses, the most magnificent in the world, consisting of a long white kilt, gold work cloak, daggers. The Tartars with their high caps, the Turks in their vast palaces stretched in groups in an immense open gallery in front of the palace, the latter placed in a kind of cloister below it, 200 steeds ready caparison to move in a moment, couriers entering or passing out with dispatches, the kettle drums beating, boys calling the hour from the minaret of the mosque, all together with the singular appearance of the building itself. So you can see this is kind of overwhelming for someone who is already primed to respond to it in the most romantic manner possible. And Tom, do they have a guide? Do we know if they have interpreters? Yes, they have guides and they have bodyguards. Right. Who they've basically hired with gold or
世界上最华丽的衣服，由长白裙、金工斗篷、匕首组成。鞑靼人戴着高帽子，土耳其人在他们巨大的宫殿里，成群结队地躺在宫殿前巨大的开放式画廊里，后者被安置在下面的一种回廊里，200匹骏马随时准备移动，信使带着公文进出，定音鼓敲响，男孩们从清真寺的尖塔呼唤时间，所有这些与建筑本身独特的外观结合在一起。所以你可以看出，这对一个已经准备好以最浪漫的方式回应它的人来说是压倒性的。汤姆，他们有向导吗？我们知道他们有翻译吗？是的，他们有向导，他们有保镖。没错。他们基本上是用黄金或
silver or whatever? Well, they've been given guards by Ali Pasha's extended family and his lieutenants are looking after them because Ali Pasha is pro-British at the time. It would have been very different if he suddenly switched sides and became French and then they'd be absolute toast. But as it is, Ali Pasha is very welcoming and seems delighted to meet Byron. So he stands to greet him, which is seen as a tremendous compliment. Also compliments Byron on his looks, compliments him on his small ears and his delicate white hands. Small ears. He loves this. And he tells him to look on him as a father. Right. Basically, Dominic, he looks a bit like
白银或任何东西雇佣的？嗯，他们得到了阿里帕夏大家庭的守卫，他的副官在照顾他们，因为阿里帕夏当时是亲英的。如果他突然倒戈变成法国人，那情况就会大不相同，他们就会彻底完蛋。但事实是，阿里帕夏非常欢迎，似乎很高兴见到拜伦。所以他站起来迎接他，这被视为一种巨大的恭维。还称赞拜伦的长相，称赞他小巧的耳朵和精致的白手。小耳朵。他喜欢这个。他告诉他把他看作父亲。没错。基本上，多米尼克，他看起来有点像
Captain Edward Smith. Oh, our old friend from the Titanic. Very accomplished captain. Yeah. He's got a kind of white beard. He's stout. Quite jolly in appearance. And Byron is fascinated by the fact that this guy who basically looks like Father Christmas is also a man who rapes and murders and impales and roasts his enemies. Kind of, I think, identifies with him. Well, I was about to say, for Byron, I'm guessing, knowing Byron now through your account, that Byron rather idolizes somebody who roasts his enemies and leaves a sort of trail of deflowered virgins and burning villages in his wake. Because Byron has that fascination with the darkness, doesn't he? He has that fascination with the extremes. Well, you see, what's interesting, I think, is that had it been Wellington soldiers in Spain doing these atrocities, Byron would hate it.
爱德华·史密斯船长。哦，我们泰坦尼克号的老朋友。非常有成就的船长。是的。他有某种白胡子。他很胖。外表相当快活。拜伦被这个事实迷住了，这个看起来像圣诞老人的家伙也是一个强奸、谋杀、刺穿并烤熟敌人的男人。某种程度上，我想，认同他。嗯，我正要说，对于拜伦，我猜，通过你的叙述了解拜伦，拜伦相当崇拜一个烤熟敌人并留下一串被破处的处女和燃烧村庄的人。因为拜伦对黑暗有那种迷恋，不是吗？他有那种对极端的迷恋。嗯，你看，有趣的是，我认为，如果是威灵顿在西班牙的士兵犯下这些暴行，拜伦会讨厌它。
But because it's exotic and glamorous and well-dressed, he feels slightly different about it. And the measure of his sense of identification with the Albanians is probably the most famous painting of him that I imagine most listeners will have some sense of, the kind of the pose where he's wearing this kind of flamboyant Albanian costume. And if you don't know it, we'll put it on our Twitter feed. And you asked about who is looking after him. This is where Ali Pasha gives Byron a kind of servant, a kind of bodyguard, a man called Vasily. Vasily is a person who has participated in a particularly famous atrocity when Ali Pasha's daughter-in-law had complained to Ali that her husband was going after other women, and in particular names a 17-year-old Greek girl. And Ali Pasha,
但因为它是异国情调、迷人且穿着考究，他对此感觉略有不同。他与阿尔巴尼亚人认同感的衡量标准可能是他最著名的画作，我想大多数听众都会有一些感觉，那种他穿着这种浮夸的阿尔巴尼亚服装的姿势。如果你不知道，我们会把它放在我们的推特上。你问是谁在照顾他。这就是阿里帕夏给拜伦一个仆人，一个保镖，一个叫瓦西里的人的地方。瓦西里是一个参与了特别著名的暴行的人，当时阿里帕夏的儿媳向阿里抱怨她的丈夫在追求其他女人，特别是点名了一个17岁的希腊女孩。阿里帕夏，
even though this Greek girl was completely blameless, I mean, she'd been raped by Ali Pasha's son. Nevertheless, he orders the girl to be sewn into a sack, 16 of her closest friends also to be sewn into sacks, and then thrown from the fortress wall into the lake. And Vasily had taken part in this. And I think Byron feels there's a kind of terrible glamour about this. And in fact, he will write about a Westerner whose girlfriend suffers exactly this fate in a famous poem called The Jower. One of those poems that kind of helps to make his name. So I think Byron clearly is identifying with Ali Pasha, but it may be that something more
即使这个希腊女孩完全无辜，我的意思是，她被阿里帕夏的儿子强奸了。尽管如此，他还是命令把女孩缝进麻袋，她的16个最亲密的朋友也被缝进麻袋，然后从堡垒墙上扔进湖里。瓦西里参与了这件事。我认为拜伦觉得这有一种可怕的魅力。事实上，他将在一首名为《异教徒》的著名诗中写到一个女朋友遭受这种命运的西方人。那些有助于让他成名的诗之一。所以我认为拜伦显然在认同阿里帕夏，但可能还有些更多
happens between them as well. So I mentioned that Byron had taken his page boy, Robert Rushton, with him, but he'd actually sent him back from Gibraltar on the grounds that boys are not safe among the Turks. And it may be that, you know, 19-year-old peers aren't safe among the Turks either, because basically all that kind of complimenting Byron, telling him, oh, look on me like your father. Yeah. You know, Ali Pasha is sending him little sweets. I like your little ears.
的事情也发生在他们之间。所以我提到拜伦带了他的侍从男孩罗伯特·拉什顿，但他实际上以男孩在土耳其人中不安全为由把他从直布罗陀送回去了。可能，你知道，19岁的贵族在土耳其人中也不安全，因为基本上所有那种恭维拜伦，告诉他，哦，把我当成你的父亲。是的。你知道，阿里帕夏在给他送小甜点。我喜欢你的小耳朵。
Sherbet and fruit. I mean, he's behaving like a sugar daddy. Oh, you think something happened between Byron and Ali Pasha? Not clear. But Byron drops quite a few hints about it. And we'll see in the second half, Byron is interested in a certain degree of gender fluidity. He likes to play the kind of the rake, but he does also, there is a certain quality of submissiveness, a kind of passivity perhaps. So it's kind of complex. Anyway, so Byron is having
果子露和水果。我的意思是，他的行为就像一个糖爹。哦，你认为拜伦和阿里帕夏之间发生了什么？不清楚。但拜伦对此暗示了不少。我们将在下半部分看到，拜伦对某种程度的性别流动性感兴趣。他喜欢扮演那种浪子，但他确实也，有一种顺从的品质，某种被动性也许。所以这有点复杂。无论如何，所以拜伦正在度过
a lovely time. It's exciting. It's thrilling. It's kind of dangerous. Meanwhile, Hobhouse and Fletcher, Byron's valet, are continuing to crumble. Hobhouse is now complaining that he can't find someone to repair his umbrella. Not much call for umbrellas in Albania, I guess. Yeah, exactly. Byron is basically, I think, fired by a sense of how exciting life can be. As he leaves Albania and heading towards Athens, they're going via the site of Delphi, Thebes, so they're heading back into classical Greece, all the stuff that Byron had read about at school. He is starting work on Childe Harold's pilgrimage. I think as he goes, he is starting to get an elevated sense of what his destiny might be. So in the Child Harold pilgrimage, he has this line, who now shall call thy scattered children
一段美好的时光。这很令人兴奋。这很惊险。这有点危险。与此同时，霍布豪斯和弗莱彻，拜伦的贴身男仆，正在继续崩溃。霍布豪斯现在抱怨他找不到人修理他的雨伞。我想阿尔巴尼亚对雨伞没什么需求。是的，完全正确。拜伦基本上，我想，被一种生活可以如此令人兴奋的感觉所点燃。当他离开阿尔巴尼亚前往雅典时，他们经由德尔斐、底比斯，所以他们正前往古典希腊，所有拜伦在学校读过的东西。他开始创作《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》。我想当他走的时候，他开始对他的命运可能是什么有一种崇高的感觉。所以在《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中，他有这样一行，谁现在将召唤你分散的孩子
forth, address to Greece. And in the very earliest version of the poem, he writes this line out five times and five times he writes down as the answer, Byron. And so right at this earliest point, he hasn't even reached Athens yet. It is as though he's been inspired by everything that he's seen to cast himself as the future savior of Greece. A lunatic ambition, you might think, Tom, but of course that's how Byron ends up being remembered. So maybe not so lunatic. And he's on his way to Athens he's had this shall we say colorful interlude in Albania but yet more colorful adventures await and we will find out what happens to him in Athens after the break
出来，致希腊。在诗的最早版本中，他把这一行写了五次，五次他写下的答案是，拜伦。所以就在这个最早的点，他甚至还没有到达雅典。就好像他被他所看到的一切所激励，把自己塑造成希腊未来的救世主。一个疯狂的野心，你可能会想，汤姆，但当然这就是拜伦最终被记住的方式。所以也许没那么疯狂。他正在去雅典的路上，他在阿尔巴尼亚度过了这段，我们称之为丰富多彩的插曲，但还有更多丰富多彩的冒险在等待，我们将在休息后找出他在雅典发生了什么
I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Slow Sinks. Slow sinks, more lovely ere his race be run,
我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻评论、秀场八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。缓慢下沉。缓慢下沉，更可爱，在他赛跑结束之前，
Along Moraya's hills, the setting sun, Not as in northern climes obscurely bright, But one unclouded blaze of living light. Ah, the hush deep the yellow beam he throws gilds the green wave that trembles as it glows. On old Aegina's rock and Hydra's isle the god of gladness sheds his parting smile. O'er his own regions lingering loves to shine, though there his altars are no more divine.
沿着莫拉亚的山丘，落日，不像在北方气候中那样模糊地明亮，而是一道无云的生命之光。啊，他投下的黄色光束是多么深沉，镀金了颤抖的绿色波浪。在古老的埃吉纳岩石和伊兹拉岛上，欢乐之神洒下了他离别的微笑。在他自己的地区徘徊，喜欢闪耀，尽管他的祭坛在那里不再神圣。
Descending fast, the mountain shadows kiss, thy glorious gulf, unconquered Salamis. So that's The Curse of Minerva by our old friend Lord Byron, written, Tom, in Athens. Yes. And lots of, as you have written in your notes, lots of favourite Byronic themes. Yeah. So you've got the contrast between the brightness of Greece and the drizzle of Britain. You've got the contrast between the glory that was Greece and its present slavery, all that kind of thing. But the poem itself, actually, its principal theme is a topic that remains controversial to this day. And it's a satire, and the object of Byron's satire is Lord Elgin. Yeah, the hero of the marbles.
快速下降，山影亲吻，你光荣的海湾，未被征服的萨拉米斯。这就是我们老朋友拜伦勋爵的《密涅瓦的诅咒》，汤姆，写于雅典。是的。正如你在笔记中所写，有很多最喜欢的拜伦主题。是的。所以你有希腊的明亮与英国的细雨之间的对比。你有曾经是希腊的荣耀与它现在的奴役之间的对比，所有这些东西。但诗本身，实际上，它的主要主题是一个至今仍有争议的话题。这是一部讽刺作品，拜伦讽刺的对象是埃尔金勋爵。是的，大理石的英雄。
The man who brings the Parthenon freezes back from the Acropolis, the Elgin marbles. Byron is appalled by this. Actually, he writes about it in Childe Harold's Pilgrimage as well. It kind of obsesses him for reasons that I think are very interesting. So, Byron and Hobhouse have been traveling from Albania through the autumn and into the winter through Greece, and they're heading for Athens. And they arrive in Athens on Christmas Day, 1809. And unsurprisingly, when they arrive there, full of visions of the Athens, of Pericles and Phidias and Socrates, they're incredibly disappointed because Athens is a pretty rundown, bedraggled, squalid shadow of what it had once been.
那个把帕特农神庙的饰带从卫城带回来的人，埃尔金大理石雕。拜伦对此感到震惊。实际上，他在《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中也写到了这一点。它以我认为非常有趣的原因让他着迷。所以，拜伦和霍布豪斯从秋天到冬天一直从阿尔巴尼亚穿过希腊，他们正前往雅典。他们于1809年圣诞节抵达雅典。不出所料，当他们到达那里时，充满了伯里克利、菲迪亚斯和苏格拉底的雅典的幻象，他们感到非常失望，因为雅典是一个相当破旧、邋遢、肮脏的曾经的影子。
Kind of weeds growing in the cracks in the pavements kind of thing, isn't it? Narrow, crooked streets. I mean, there's no more than 10,000 people living there. And Hobhouse goes to walk around the walls and he times himself and takes him 47 minutes. But again, Byron kind of loves Athens. He'll be incredibly happy there. He and Hobhouse rent this beautiful house with a courtyard. It's got a lemon tree in the middle of it.
人行道裂缝里长着杂草的那种，对吧？狭窄、弯曲的街道。我的意思是，那里住的人不超过10,000人。霍布豪斯去绕着城墙走，他给自己计时，花了47分钟。但同样，拜伦有点爱上了雅典。他会在那里非常快乐。他和霍布豪斯租了这栋带庭院的美丽房子。中间有一棵柠檬树。
Unlike Albania, there are lots of international visitors there, Byron's kind of people. He settles into kind of expat life. Lots of sex, lots of sexual opportunities. Boys or girls, or both? Both, I think. Right. Okay. There's a lot of kind of editing going on of Byron's papers. And in fact, Hobhouse, while he's out there, makes Byron burn a whole load of stuff that Byron's written. So we can't be absolutely certain, but I think probably both. There are lots of antiquities and Byron has this kind of growing sympathy for the cause of
与阿尔巴尼亚不同，那里有很多国际游客，都是拜伦那种人。他适应了某种外籍人士的生活。有很多性行为，有很多性机会。男孩还是女孩，或者两者都有？我想两者都有。没错。好吧。拜伦的文稿经过了大量的编辑。事实上，霍布豪斯在当地时，让拜伦烧毁了大量他写的东西。所以我们不能完全确定，但我认为很可能是两者都有。那里有很多古物，拜伦对希腊自由事业的同情心日益增长。
Greek liberty. And I think that it's that sense that he is there to defend Greece that makes him find in Lord Elgin's transportation of the friezes from the Parthenon a way of channeling that. Lord Elgin is Scottish, Byron's mother is Scottish, and so Byron comes to see Lord Elgin as the embodiment of everything that he's escaped. The provincialism that he associates with Britain, the philistinism, and as I say, above all, his mother, who he's never particularly got on with. So kind of deep waters. So the way that Byron comes to be obsessed by the Elgin Marbles is that two days after
我认为正是那种他身处此地是为了保卫希腊的感觉，使他从埃尔金勋爵将帕台农神庙的饰带运走这件事中找到了一种宣泄方式。埃尔金勋爵是苏格兰人，拜伦的母亲也是苏格兰人，因此拜伦开始将埃尔金勋爵视为他所逃避的一切的化身。他与英国联系在一起的狭隘主义、庸俗主义，正如我所说，最重要的是他的母亲，他从未与她相处融洽。所以，这水很深。拜伦之所以对埃尔金大理石雕塑如此痴迷，是因为在它们到达两天后，
they've arrived, so the 27th of December, he and Hobhouse are visited by an art connoisseur and collector from Naples by the name of Giovanni Battista Lucieri. And Lucieri had originally come to Greece as the agent of Sir William Hamilton, Dominic. Oh no, Sir William Hamilton. So he's the British envoy. Cuckolded by Nelson. Yeah, the British envoy in Naples. Married to Emma Hamilton, who's always doing her attitudes, isn't she? And Sir William Hamilton is obsessed with, I mean, he's a great antiquarian. He's obsessed with kind of Greek vases and- Yeah, he was in Love Island.
也就是12月27日，一位来自那不勒斯的艺术鉴赏家和收藏家乔瓦尼·巴蒂斯塔·卢西耶里拜访了他和霍布豪斯。卢西耶里最初是作为威廉·汉密尔顿爵士的代理人来到希腊的，多米尼克。哦，不，威廉·汉密尔顿爵士。所以他是英国特使。被纳尔逊戴了绿帽子。是的，那不勒斯的英国特使。娶了艾玛·汉密尔顿，她总是摆出各种姿态，不是吗？威廉·汉密尔顿爵士痴迷于，我的意思是，他是一位伟大的古物研究者。他痴迷于希腊花瓶和——是的，他参加过《恋爱岛》。
Yeah. And he performed poorly, as I recall. Yeah, he didn't do well. But anyway, so Lucieri is sent by William Hamilton to kind of make drawings of the antiquities. And then in 1799, he's hired by Lord Elgin, who at the time is the ambassador to Constantinople, to make drawings for him of the antiquities. And Lucieri reports back to Elgin in Constantinople that on the Parthenon, there are these friezes that date back to the original building of the temple in the time of Pericles. They're very, very beautiful, but they are also deteriorating very very fast and badly and so therefore elgin worried about the fact that they may not last very long and so elgin because he's been told that they're deteriorating gets permission for lucieri to go and make casts of
是的。据我记得，他表现不佳。是的，他做得不好。但无论如何，卢西耶里被威廉·汉密尔顿派去为这些古物绘制图纸。然后在1799年，他被当时担任君士坦丁堡大使的埃尔金勋爵聘用，为他绘制古物图纸。卢西耶里向君士坦丁堡的埃尔金报告说，在帕台农神庙上，有这些可以追溯到伯里克利时代神庙最初建造时的饰带。它们非常非常漂亮，但也正在迅速且严重地恶化，因此埃尔金担心它们可能无法长久保存，所以埃尔金因为被告知它们正在恶化，就获得了许可，让卢西耶里去制作它们的石膏模型。
them and so the scaffolding goes up and lucieri is able to go up and look at the freezes up close he reports back to elgin says yeah they brilliant. They're even better than I'd imagined. And Elkin then thinks, well, I've got the scaffolding up. They're deteriorating. Why not take them back? Take them down, yeah. Why not remove them? Yeah. And so he, I mean, he offers bribes to get permission to remove them, but everyone is offering bribes. That's the way things are done.
于是脚手架搭了起来，卢西耶里得以近距离观察这些饰带。他向埃尔金报告说，是的，它们太棒了。它们甚至比我想象的还要好。埃尔金于是想，好吧，我已经搭好了脚手架。它们正在恶化。为什么不把它们带回去呢？把它们拆下来，是的。为什么不把它们移走呢？是的。所以他，我的意思是，他提供贿赂以获得移走它们的许可，但每个人都在提供贿赂。事情就是这样办的。
That's the Ottoman system. Right. And no objections are raised at the time, either by the Turkish government or by any Greek, about what Elgin is doing. And in fact, the only objection comes from the garrison on the Acropolis, because the Acropolis is the Ottoman military garrison, who were worried that Lucieri's workmen will be able to peer into the garrison's harem. I love that detail. And so this has been ongoing for 10 years. And just before Baron's arrival, the last freeze has been taken down and is down at Piraeus, the port of Athens, waiting to be shipped off. It took them 10 years to take all this down. Yeah, it takes that long. And what is kind of adding jeopardy to the
这就是奥斯曼帝国的体制。没错。当时无论是土耳其政府还是任何希腊人，都没有对埃尔金的行为提出异议。事实上，唯一的反对意见来自卫城驻军，因为卫城是奥斯曼帝国的军事驻地，他们担心卢西耶里的工人们会窥视驻军的后宫。我喜欢这个细节。这种情况已经持续了10年。就在拜伦到达之前，最后一块饰带被拆了下来，现在在雅典的港口比雷埃夫斯，等待装船运走。他们花了10年时间才把所有这些拆下来。是的，需要那么久。而让整件事变得更加危险的是，
whole thing is that, of course, the French are sniffing around takes that long. And what is kind of adding jeopardy to the whole thing is that, of course, the French are sniffing around it as well. And so the whole process is dependent on Britain maintaining its alliance with the Ottomans, because the Anglo-French rivalry is kind of echoing through the Ottoman Empire as well. And Napoleon has an agent right on the spot, doesn't he, who's trying to get the freezes himself? Yeah, he does. And he'd actually been planning to kind of grab Elgin's last haul, but he gets put in prison because suddenly the Ottomans have a bust up with Napoleon. So good timing for Elgin. So on the 8th of January, Byron is escorted by Lucieri up to the Acropolis, and a hobhouse goes
当然，法国人也在四处打探。所以整个过程取决于英国是否能维持与奥斯曼帝国的联盟，因为英法竞争也在奥斯曼帝国境内回响。拿破仑在当地有一个代理人，不是吗？他自己也想得到这些饰带？是的，他确实有。他本来计划抢走埃尔金的最后一批货物，但他被关进了监狱，因为奥斯曼人突然与拿破仑闹翻了。所以对埃尔金来说时机正好。1月8日，拜伦在卢西耶里的陪同下前往卫城，霍布豪斯也去了。
as well. And they're appalled by what they see, because of course they have this image of it as something from the time of Pericles. But as we said, it's a garrison. And so there are gun palisades all over the place. All the various temples are part of the fortifications. The garrison have their white houses anywhere that there isn't an antiquity. And notoriously, the Parthenon itself had been used by the Turks in the 17th century as an ammunition dump. Yeah. And there'd been a siege. The Venetians had besieged it.
他们对所见所闻感到震惊，因为他们当然把这里想象成伯里克利时代的样子。但正如我们所说，这是一个驻军基地。所以到处都是炮台。所有的神庙都是防御工事的一部分。驻军在任何没有古物的地方都有他们的白色房子。众所周知，帕台农神庙本身在17世纪曾被土耳其人用作弹药库。是的。而且发生过围攻。威尼斯人围攻过它。
A cannonball had hit the ammunition dump and the Parthenon had blown up. And Byron and Hobhouse had shown the large hole in the ground where the shell had landed. Now, Hobhouse and Byron react in very, very different ways to what they're shown. Hobhouse writes in his journal that he has been told by a workman that everyone up there is just kind of burning the marble freezers for lime, that whenever they need to do building projects, they just chuck them in. Why wouldn't they? And if you burn it, you can basically melt it down or whatever. Yeah. So that is ongoing. And that's what's happening. And so Hobhouse thinks, thank God we're rescuing them.
一颗炮弹击中了弹药库，帕台农神庙爆炸了。拜伦和霍布豪斯展示了炮弹落下的地面上的大洞。现在，霍布豪斯和拜伦对他们所看到的东西反应非常非常不同。霍布豪斯在他的日记中写道，他从一个工人那里得知，上面的人只是把大理石饰带烧成石灰，每当他们需要进行建筑项目时，他们就把它们扔进去。为什么不呢？如果你烧掉它，你基本上可以把它熔化或者其他什么。是的。所以这正在进行中。这就是正在发生的事情。所以霍布豪斯想，谢天谢地，我们正在拯救它们。
So this is what Hobhouse writes in his journal. If the progress of decay should continue to be as rapid as it has been for more than a century past, there will in a few years be not one marble standing upon another on the site of the Parthenon." So Hobhouse is basically blaming the Turks. Basically, no one in Athens has any interest in them. This is true of the Greeks as well as of the Turks. Hobhouse, as an antiquarian, is appalled by this and basically thinks, well, thank God Elgin is on hand to rescue and preserve them. Byron, in Childe Harold's Pilgrimage, lists all the various barbarians who over the course of Greek history have plundered Athens. So the Romans and the Goths and the Turks. But he fixes on Lord Elgin as absolutely the worst of all the plunderers,
这就是霍布豪斯在他的日记中写的内容。“如果衰败的过程继续像过去一个多世纪那样迅速，几年之内，帕台农神庙遗址上就不会剩下一块大理石了。”所以霍布豪斯基本上是在责怪土耳其人。基本上，雅典没有人对它们感兴趣。这对希腊人和土耳其人来说都是如此。霍布豪斯作为一名古物研究者，对此感到震惊，并基本上认为，谢天谢地，埃尔金在场可以拯救和保护它们。拜伦在《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中列举了希腊历史上掠夺雅典的各种野蛮人。比如罗马人、哥特人和土耳其人。但他认定埃尔金勋爵是所有掠夺者中最糟糕的一个，
cold as the crags upon his native coast, his mind as barren and his heart as hard. It's harsh. And he's never met Elgin. Oh, he's not met him at this point. That's mad. No, he's never met Elgin. Right. Okay. But he goes after Elgin more savagely, perhaps, than almost any other person that he goes after in all his poetry. Elgin has got this disease. His nose has half been eaten away. Byron incorrectly blames it on syphilis and can't stop going on about it. He laughs at Elgin for being cuckolded by his wife, and he jeers at him as an absolute barbarian. I think it's very difficult not to feel that here
“冷酷如他故乡的峭壁，他的思想贫瘠，他的心肠坚硬。”这很刻薄。而且他从未见过埃尔金。哦，他此时还没见过他。这太疯狂了。不，他从未见过埃尔金。没错。好吧。但他攻击埃尔金的方式可能比他在所有诗歌中攻击的任何其他人都更猛烈。埃尔金患有这种疾病。他的鼻子被吃掉了一半。拜伦错误地将其归咎于梅毒，并对此喋喋不休。他嘲笑埃尔金被妻子戴了绿帽子，并嘲讽他是一个彻头彻尾的野蛮人。我认为很难不感觉到在这里，
he is channeling his resentments of the childhood in Aberdeen. And you asked, did he feel Scottish? In certain ways he does. He always identifies with the rugged beauty of the landscape. But on the other hand, so in this poem, he refers to Scotland as a land of meanness, sophistry and mist. Harsh. And sees it as the kind of anti-Greece really. So his antipathy to Elgin, obviously so much of it is projection. Yeah. And his hostility to the removal of what we used to call the Elgin marbles, the Parthenon freezes, is presumably born of the fact that he wants Greece to be his and to be pristine and perfect. And here is the British establishment of which he
他正在宣泄他在阿伯丁童年时期的怨恨。你问过，他觉得自己是苏格兰人吗？在某些方面他是。他总是认同那片土地崎岖的美景。但另一方面，在这首诗中，他将苏格兰称为“卑鄙、诡辩和迷雾之地”。刻薄。并将其视为希腊的对立面。所以他对埃尔金的反感，显然很大程度上是投射。是的。他对移走我们过去所说的“埃尔金大理石”（帕台农神庙饰带）的敌意，大概源于他希望希腊是属于他的，是原始而完美的。而这里是英国建制派，他是其产物，但他却对此感到怨恨。这里是英国建制派拿走了他的一点希腊，保护它并把它带回英国。他把这视为一种个人侮辱，不是吗？是的。就像他的童年在他……的时刻回来践踏他。对他来说更糟的是，因为他梦想着来到希腊，他对他会是什么样子有这种幻想。他会穿着他那巨大的五颜六色的裤子走来走去，骚扰男孩什么的。是的。然而苏格兰又一次跟随着他。
is the product, but which he resents. Here is the British establishment taking a bit of his Greece, preserving it and taking it back to Britain. And he takes that as a personal affront, doesn't he? Yeah. It's like his childhood has come back to stamp on him in the moment of his... And it's worse for him because he's dreamed about coming to Greece and he has this fantasy of what it'll be like. And he'll be walking around in his massive multicolored trousers, molesting boys or whatever. Yeah. And yet again, Scotland has followed him.
是的，我认为这绝对是真的。而且我认为，他与可怕的保姆和糟糕的母亲一起忍受的阴郁的阿伯丁童年，与希腊之间的对比感，因为拜伦此时此刻正过着他最好的生活而变得更加尖锐。我的意思是，毫无疑问。他过得很愉快。所以他在雅典待了10周，然后他穿过爱琴海，所有这些在废墟中摆姿势的行为。我的意思是，这就是拜伦式的精髓。爱琴海的另一边也有很多很棒的废墟。所以他去了以弗所，我相信很多听这个节目的人在去土耳其度假时可能去过那里，但那里什么都没有。拜伦骑马
Yeah, I think that's absolutely true. And I think that the sense of the contrast between the grim Aberdonian childhood that he had endured with the hideous nursemaid and his mother being awful and everything, and Greece, is sharpened by the fact that Byron is absolutely, at this point, living his best life. I mean, there's no question about it. He is having a lovely time. So he spends 10 weeks in Athens and then he crosses the Aegean and all this kind of posing amid ruins. I mean, it's the essence of the Byronic. There are loads of great ruins on the other sides of the Aegean as well. So he goes to Ephesus, a place that I'm sure lots of people listening to this may have gone on holiday when they go to Turkey, but there's nothing there. Byron goes and rides
在废墟中穿行，他报告说他听到成千上万只豺狼在那里嚎叫。然后他去了可能是土耳其乃至整个土耳其最富有氛围和最著名的古代遗址，即特洛伊，特洛伊曾经矗立的地方。现在，这远在施里曼来挖掘它之前。有各种各样的人说特洛伊从未存在过。拜伦对此非常蔑视。所以在《唐璜》中，他会说：“我站在阿喀琉斯的墓前，听到有人怀疑特洛伊。时间也会怀疑罗马。”对拜伦来说，这一切都非常生动。这一切都非常真实。这一切都是真的。他想参与到神话的维度中去。而他展示这一点最著名的方式
out among the ruins and he reports that he hears thousands of jackals howling there. And then he goes to perhaps the most atmospheric and celebrated ancient site, possibly in the whole of Turkey, which is the Troad, the place where Troy had stood. Now, this is long before Schliemann will come and dig it up. And there are all kinds of people who say that Troy had never existed. Byron is very contemptuous of this. So in Don Juan, he will say, I've stood upon Achilles' tomb and heard Troy doubted. Time will doubt of Rome. For Byron, it's all very vivid. It's all very real. It's all true. And he wants to participate in the dimension of myth. And the most famous way in which he demonstrates this
是1810年5月3日，他游过了赫勒斯滂海峡。所以赫勒斯滂海峡是土耳其分隔欧洲和亚洲的海域。说实话，这很有胆量。嗯，这确实很有胆量，因为这是一个很多人不会游泳的时期。所以我们谈到了剑桥那个据称溺水身亡的唱诗班男孩约翰·埃德尔斯顿。我的意思是，这是完全合理的。人们基本上不会游泳。而且在适当的时候，拜伦最著名的朋友之一，诗人珀西·雪莱，他也会溺水身亡。但拜伦喜欢游泳。当然，这是因为他跛脚。他有一只畸形足。所以他在水里——这很好。但拜伦喜欢游泳。当然，这是因为他跛脚。他有一只畸形足。所以他在水里——
is that on the 3rd of May, 1810, he swims the Hellespont. So the Hellespont is the sea that separates Europe and Asia in Turkey. That is gutsy, to be fair to him. Well, it is gutsy because this is a period where lots of people don't swim. So we talked about John Edelston, the choir boy in Cambridge who supposedly had drowned. I mean, this is perfectly plausible. People can't basically swim. And in due course, one of Byron's most celebrated friends, Percy Shelley, the poet, he will drown as well. But Byron loves swimming. And that, of course, is because he's lame. He has a club foot. And so in the water- It's as good as well. But Byron loves swimming. And that of course is because he's lame. He has a club foot. And so in the water-
他和任何人一样好。他完全可以自由活动。是的。是的，他抓住每一个游泳的机会。所以他实际上在游赫勒斯滂海峡之前，就已经游过一段更令人印象深刻的距离，那就是横渡里斯本的塔霍河。哦，那距离相当远。是的。所以这是一项更艰巨的壮举。是的。但当然，赫勒斯滂海峡是最浪漫的，因为在希腊神话中，利安德曾游过海峡去见他在对岸塔楼里的爱人希罗。
It's as good as anybody. He's perfectly mobile. Yeah. Yes. And every opportunity to swim he takes. So he had actually already, before he'd done the Hellespont, he'd swum an even more impressive length, which is across the Tagus in Lisbon. Oh, that's quite a distance. Yeah. So it's a much tougher feat. Yeah. But of course, the Hellespont is the most romantic because in Greek mythology, Leander had swum across to his beloved in a tower on the other side, Hero.
所以拜伦想效仿利安德横渡海峡的壮举。他用了一小时10分钟完成了。陪同他的是一位皇家海军军官，威廉·埃肯黑德中尉。多年后，他仍然对此感到无比自豪，所以他在《唐璜》中写道，这是一项我们引以为豪的壮举，“利安德、埃肯黑德先生和我做到了”，所以非常非常自豪。有道理，我的意思是，我为他脱帽致敬。没错。所以他们现在正航行在赫勒斯滂海峡上，前往奥斯曼帝国的首都君士坦丁堡。他们于5月13日到达那里，他们不被允许进入旧君士坦丁堡，即拜占庭帝国和后来的奥斯曼帝国的所在地。相反，他们必须待在一个叫佩拉的地方，它在加拉塔上方，
And so Byron wants to emulate the feat of Leander in swimming across. And he does it in an hour and 10 minutes. And he's accompanied by an officer in the Royal Navy, Lieutenant William Eckenhead and again years later he's still incredibly proud of it so again he writes about it in don juan that it was a feat on which ourselves we prided leander mr eckenhead and i did so very very proud of it fair enough i mean i'd take my hat off to him for that. Right. So they are now sailing up the Hellespont, going up towards Constantinople, the capital of the Ottoman Empire. And they arrive there on the 13th of May, and they're not allowed into old Constantinople, the seat of the Byzantine and then the Ottoman Empire. Instead, they have to stay in a place called Pera, which is above the Galata,
所以与旧君士坦丁堡中心隔着金角湾相对。是的。是的。它现在是伊斯坦布尔的商业中心。是的。他们发现这是一种奇怪的，对拜伦来说令人兴奋的异国情调与熟悉的混合体。所以他们必须从带他们来的船上乘船，你知道，划船穿过加拉塔港。当他们走的时候，他们抬头看着宫殿的墙壁，看到后宫在哪里，他们看到狗在墙下吞食一具尸体。这，就像拜伦在旅行中看到的许多东西一样，后来当他写一首名为《科林斯围城》的诗时，会启发他。
so opposite on the far side of the Golden Horn from the old centre of Constantinople. Yes. Yeah. It's now the kind of commercial heart of Istanbul. Yeah. And they find it a kind of weird and for Bayer an exciting mix of the exotic and the familiar. So they have to take boat from the ship that's brought them, you know, that will row them across to the harbour at Galata. And as they're going, they look up at the palace walls and they see where the harem is, and they see dogs devouring a corpse there beneath the wall. And this, like so much that Byron sees on his trips, this will inspire him later when he comes to write a poem called The
“他看到墙下瘦骨嶙峋的狗，守着死者，它们的狂欢，吞噬着尸体和肢体。它们太忙了，没空对他吠叫。”但与之相对的是，当他到达那里时，他们发现有一家带台球桌的酒店。哦，太棒了。他们已经很久没有玩过了。这就像终极的19世纪英国旅行，不是吗？死狗，但也有台球。是的。所以，拜伦现在，我的意思是，他非常自在。他过得很愉快，他基本上已经成为一种美丽和魅力的象征，不仅对西方同胞，甚至对土耳其人本身也是如此。所以，他们发现他很迷人。7月10日，他受到了苏丹的接见。马哈茂德二世，汤姆。
Siege of Corinth. He saw the lean dogs beneath the wall, holder the dead, their carnival, gorging and growling a carcass and limb. They were too busy to bark at him. But against that, when he arrives there, they find there's a hotel with a billiard table. Oh, brilliant. Which they haven't had, you know, for a very long time. This is like the ultimate 19th century British trip, isn't it? Dead dogs, but also billions. Yeah. So, Byron is now, I mean, he's very much at home. He's having a lovely time, and he's basically become a figure of kind of beauty and glamour, not just for fellow Westerners, but even for the Turks themselves. So, they find him fascinating And on the 10th of July, he is received by the Sultan. Mahmud II, Tom.
所以他在奥斯曼世界很有名，因为他是那个打击了耶尼切里军团权力的人，他们是伟大的，你知道，他们被选为精英军事军团。他们掌握着权力。他们一直是那种禁卫军。但马哈茂德最终也成为了一位伟大的西化者，所以他预示了所谓的“坦齐马特”，即奥斯曼帝国伟大的改革时期。他喜欢拜伦，不是吗？他非常喜欢拜伦。是的，就像阿里帕夏一样。所以有一个目击者说，
So he's famous in the Ottoman world because he's the guy who's cracked down on the power of the Janissaries, who are the great kind of, they've been selected to be an elite kind of military corps. And they held power. They've been that kind of Praetorian guard. But also Mahmud ends up being a great westernizer so he anticipates what's called the tantamount which is the great period of reform for the ottoman empire and he loves byron doesn't he is very taken with byron yeah just as ali pasha had been so so there's a witness to it and says that the
苏丹对他年轻而引人注目的外表以及他华丽的服装印象深刻。事实上，苏丹认为拜伦是一个女扮男装的女人。他一直这么认为。关于这一点，有趣的是，拜伦在旅行过程中一直在探索他的女性一面。所以霍布豪斯在雅典时，在他的日记中记录道：“拜伦穿上女装并与德米特里厄斯跳舞后，吃完饭去睡觉。”在《唐璜》中，他的英雄唐璜伪装成奴隶女孩进入了后宫。所以对于拜伦和整个东方来说，君士坦丁堡的浪漫和异国情调中有一种性别流动性，性别游戏，我认为还有
sultan was much struck by his youthful and striking appearance and the splendor of his dress. And in fact, the Sultan thinks that Byron is a woman dressed as a man. And he always thinks that. And kind of what's intriguing about that is that Byron has, over the course of his trip, been exploring his female side. So Hobhouse, while they're in Athens, had recorded in his journal, dined to bed after Byron dressing up in female apparel and dancing with Demetrius. And in Don Juan, his hero, Don Juan, enters the harem disguised as a slave girl. So there's a kind of part of the romance and exoticism of Constantinople for Byron and the East generally, I think. There's a sense of gender fluidity, gender play going on as well as
其他一切。天哪。非常21世纪。所以你可以理解为什么随着所有这种个人探索的进行，它是文学的、文化的、心理的、性的。拜伦一点也不想回家。霍布豪斯现在必须，你知道，他被家人召回，他们经历了一次感人的告别。但我认为拜伦相当如释重负，因为霍布豪斯比他更像个在国外的英国人。你知道，他抱怨雨伞和厕所之类的东西。在适当的时候，拜伦的朋友，诗人托马斯·摩尔为拜伦写的第一部传记，
everything else. Crikey. Very 21st century. And so you can understand why with all this kind of sense of personal exploration going on, it's kind of literary, it's cultural, it's psychological, it's sexual. Byron's not keen to go home at all. Hobhouse by now has to, you know, he's being summoned back by his family and they have this emotional parting. But I think Byron is quite relieved because Hobhouse is much more the Englishman abroad than he is. You know, he's moaning about umbrellas and toilets and things. And in due course, the first biography that is written of Byron by a friend of Byron's
他在这一点上对拜伦的孤独需求进行了狂想。他变得如此迷恋这些孤独的沉思，以至于即使是他旅伴的陪伴——摩尔指的是霍布豪斯，尽管他的追求与他自己的非常契合——最终也成了他的枷锁和负担。直到他独自站在爱琴海小岛的岸边，他才感到自己的灵魂自由呼吸。霍布豪斯读到了这一点。他不高兴，是吗？他一点也不高兴。他在页边空白处写道：“汤姆是根据什么权威这么说的？他根本无法理解拜伦勋爵宁愿身边没有英国人直接或持续陪伴的真正原因。”
Thomas More, who was also a poet, he at this point kind of rhapsodised on Byron's called Thomas More, who was also a poet. He, at this point, kind of rhapsodised on Byron's need for solitude. So enamoured had he become of these lonely musings that even the society of his fellow traveller, by which More means Hobhouse, though with pursuits so congenial to his own, grew at last to be a chain and a burden on him. And it was not till he stood companionless on the shore of the little island in the Aegean that he found his spirit breathe freely. And Hobhouse read this. He's not happy, is he? He was not happy at all. And he wrote in the margin, on what authority does Tom say this? He has not the remotest grasp of the real reason
好吧，汤姆。所以这就提出了一个问题，拜伦勋爵不想让英国人直接或持续陪伴在身边的真正原因是什么？我不认为在听了两个小时左右关于拜伦勋爵的故事后，我猜很多听众会认为，也许拜伦不想让另一个英国旅行者靠近他的原因
which induced Lord B to prefer having no Englishman immediately or constantly near him. Okay, Tom. So that raises the question, what is the real reason why Lord B doesn't want an Englishman immediately or constantly near him? And I don't think after two hours or so of Lord Byron, I'm guessing a lot of listeners will be thinking maybe the reason that Byron doesn't want another English traveller near him
现在在君士坦丁堡，是因为他实际上在做坏事。在性方面，他的表现比以往任何时候都更糟。嗯，你说做坏事。在性方面，他的表现比以往任何时候都更糟。嗯，你说做坏事。拜伦此时以一种心照不宣的口吻写道：“在英国，人们有他们的烟斗和啤酒。而在土耳其，他们有他们的鸦片和男孩。我真的看不出有什么区别。”这一切都是文化相对的。这就是世界公民那种心照不宣的语调。我认为，这就是他看待它的方式。但霍布豪斯，他带来了他的英国道德。
now in Constantinople is that he's actually up to no good. Sexually, he's behaving worse than ever. Well, you say up to no good. Sexually, he's behaving worse than ever. Well, you say up to no good. Byron writes back at this point in a kind of knowing turn. In England, people have their pipes and beer. And in Turkey, they have their opium and boys. And I really can't see any difference. It's all culturally relative. And this is the kind of the knowing tone of the citizen of the world. That is, I think, how he sees it. But Hobhouse, who has brought his English morality with him.
嗯，霍布豪斯有点，我的意思是，霍布豪斯对此持矛盾态度，我想。但也许那种矛盾，拜伦不想要那种矛盾。他希望霍布豪斯完全投入其中。我想那是对的。而且他意识到他的朋友们的一部分，他最好的伙伴可能对此感到不安。是的。并且正在为此挣扎。他认为最好不要有……我想是这样。
Well, Hobhouse is kind of, I mean, Hobhouse is ambivalent about it, I think. But maybe that ambivalence, Byron doesn't want that ambivalence. He wants Hobhouse to be all in on it. I think that's right. And he's conscious that part of his friends, that his great pal is perhaps disturbed about it. Yeah. And wrestling with that. And he thinks it'd be better off to have no... I think so.
是的，我想是这样。是的。所以无论如何，拜伦又待了九个月，但最终他不得不回去，基本上是因为他没钱了。是的。而且因为他所有的朋友都要为他在英国的债务负责，他们都有被捕的危险。所以拜伦觉得他必须回去。
Yes, I think so. Yeah. So anyway, so Byron stays another nine months, but eventually he has to go back basically because he's running out of money. Yeah. And because all his friends are liable for his debts back in England and they're all in danger of being arrested. So Byron feels he has to go back.
是的，我知道。所以他从雅典乘船前往马耳他，船上载着最后一批帕台农神庙饰带。所以这很讽刺。卢西耶里实际上也在这艘船上。他回去感到非常沮丧。所以他写信给霍布豪斯：“我如此缺乏精神、希望、幽默、金钱、健康。”在马耳他，他加入了一艘运兵船，并于1811年7月11日回到英国，在希尔内斯登陆。所以是在中途。是的。他回来了，他23岁，他仍然不知道该做什么。他有那种感觉，我想当你年轻时去国外，
Yeah, I know. So he takes ship from Athens to Malta on a ship that is carrying the last consignment of the Parthenon freezes. So kind of very ironic. And Lucieri is actually sailing on the ship as well. And he's very depressed to be going back. So he writes to Hobhouse, I'm so out of spirits and hopes and humour and pocket and pocket and health and in malta he joins a troop ship and he is back in england on the 11th of july 1811 lands at sheer ness so in the midway yeah and he comes back and he's 23 and he still doesn't know what to do and he has that thing that i guess so often when you go abroad when you're
度过了一段美妙的时光，看到了各种不可思议的事情，然后你回来发现你所有的朋友都变成了成年人。是的。他们都是管理顾问。是的。而你，汤姆·霍兰德，从印度回来了。没错。你不是穿着印度服装回来的吗？这不是真的吗？所有那种事情。是的。拜伦式的服装。所以拜伦回来了，他发现他的校友们穿着怪异的伪装，穿着卫兵、牧师、绅士和其他化装舞会的服装，他有一种恐慌，你知道，再次，人们离开大学或什么的，想着“是的，我该做什么？我会抓住任何我能做的工作。”所以拜伦，我的意思是，拜伦的等同于
young and you've had an amazing time and you've seen all kinds of incredible things and you come back and you find that all your friends have become grownups. Yeah. They're all management consultants. Yeah. And you, Tom Holland, have come back from India. Exactly. Did you not come back in Indian garb? Is that not correct? All that kind of thing. Yeah. Byronic garb. So Byron comes back and he finds his schoolfellas in monstrous disguises in the garb of guardsmen, parsons fine gentlemen and such other masquerade dresses and he has this kind of panic that you know again people leaving university or whatever thinking yeah what am i going to do i'll grab any job i can and so byron i mean byron's equivalent of
离开并成为一个，我不知道，什么的，是的，他考虑请求威灵顿公爵给他一个职位。我的意思是，那是他有多绝望的衡量标准。你能想象吗？是的。我认为部分原因是他的天性，你知道，他并不真的想要一份工作，但也因为他回来发现英国比他离开时在性方面更加紧张。
going off and becoming a i don't know whatever yeah is he contemplates asking the duke of wellington for a commission. I mean, that's a measure of how desperate he is. Can you imagine? Yeah. And I think part of that is his natural, you know, he doesn't really want a job, but it's also because he comes back to find that England is even more kind of sexually uptight than when he'd left.
霍布豪斯明确告诉拜伦：“不要告诉马修斯你的性冒险经历。”尽管马修斯是伟大的卫理公会教徒。是的，但马修斯，你知道，他会泄露出去。而且事实上，讽刺的是，马修斯也写信给拜伦说：“你知道，你必须小心。”他写信告诉他一件可怕的丑闻，一群绅士在伦敦市中心维尔街的一个私人会议室里被发现，他们在干草市场被示众。马修斯描述了那天整个伦敦是如何陷入骚乱的，那些绅士是如何被弄得满身泥泞，被粪便投掷。
And Hobhouse explicitly tells Byron, do not tell Matthews about your sexual adventures. Even though Matthews was the great Methodist. Yeah, but Matthews, you know, he'll blab about it. And actually, ironically, Matthews also has written to Byron saying, you know, you've got to be careful. And he writes to him about this terrible scandal where a club of gentlemen had been found in a private meeting room in Veer Street in central London, and they'd been pilloried in the hay market. And Matthews described how all London was in an uproar on that day, how the said gents were bemired and beordered, so pelted with dung.
这对拜伦来说太可怕了。更让他沮丧的是，他一回来，每个人都开始死去。所以他的母亲在他能去看她之前就去世了。他被告知，是的，她病得很重。他赶过去，但她在他到达之前就死了。不久之后，马修斯去世了，溺水身亡，不清楚是否是自杀。拜伦写道：“某种诅咒悬在我的心头。我的母亲躺在这所房子里的一具尸体。我最好的朋友之一在沟里溺水身亡。我能说什么、想什么或做什么？”
So that's terrifying for Byron. And adding to his gloom is the fact that no sooner does he get back than everyone starts dying. So his mother dies before he can go and see her. He's told, yeah, she's very ill. He rushes up, but she's dead before she gets there. Soon afterwards, Matthew dies, drowned, and it's unclear whether it's suicide or not. Byron writes and says, some curse hangs over me in mind. My mother lies a corpse in this house. One of my best friends is drowned in a ditch. What can I say or think or do?
然后在10月，他被告知他的第一个伟大的爱人，他心中纪念为纯真爱情典范的约翰·埃德尔斯顿也去世了。所以对他来说非常非常阴郁。但唯一让他振作起来的是他的文学事业似乎进展顺利。所以在他回来的第二天，他的一位远房亲戚，一个叫罗伯特·达拉斯的人拜访了他，他基本上已经自封为拜伦的文学经纪人。他问他离开时是否写了什么。拜伦给他看了他写的各种诗，达拉斯想，哦，它们不太好。他说，好吧，你确定吗？你还有别的东西吗？所以拜伦然后相当羞怯地递给他手稿
Then in October, he's informed that his first great love, whom he's commemorated in his heart as the model of an innocent love, John Edelston, that he has died as well. So very, very grim for him. But the only thing that cheers him up is that his literary career seems to be going well. So on his second day back, he gets visited by a distant relative of his, a guy called Robert Dallas, who basically has kind of appointed himself Byron's literary agent. And he asks him if he's written anything while he's been away. And Byron shows him kind of various poems that he's written and Dallas thinks, oh, they're not very good. And he says, well, you sure? Haven't you got anything else? And so Byron then rather kind of diffidently hands him the manuscript
《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》。他在希腊和土耳其时一直在乱涂乱画。是的。达拉斯读了之后被震撼了。他写信给拜伦：“你写了我读过的最令人愉快的诗之一。我被《恰尔德·哈罗德》迷住了，以至于我无法放下它。”汤姆，回顾一下，这是以拜伦自己在欧洲的航行为蓝本的长篇史诗，对吧？是的。而且它的核心有这种注定失败的拜伦式英雄的形象。所以达拉斯基本上，你知道，他扮演了布莱恩·爱普斯坦的角色，而乔治·马丁是一位名叫约翰·默里的出版商，他经营的不仅仅是出版业务，还有图书销售业务。
of Childe Harold's Pilgrimage. Which he's been scribbling while he was in Greece and Turkey. Yes. And Dallas reads it and is blown away. And he writes to Byron, you have written one of the most delightful poems I have ever read. I have been so fascinated with Childe Harold that I've not been able to lay it down. And just to recap, Tom, this is the long sort of epic poem that is modelled on Byron's own voyages across Europe. Yeah. And which has this kind of image of the doomed Byronic hero at its heart. So Dallas is basically, you know, he plays Brian Epstein and the George Martin is a publisher called John Murray, who runs not just a publishing business, but a book selling business.
是的。他有一系列出版物。所以他的畅销书是杰米·奥利弗或类似的等价物。那是朗德夫人的《家庭烹饪》。是的。但他还出版教科书、海军名录和简·奥斯汀的小说。虽然默里是托利党人，而拜伦对托利党人非常怀疑，但他们实际上相处得非常好。他们有一种非常有创造力的编辑关系。拜伦很高兴
Yes. And he has a whole array of publications. So his bestseller is kind of Jamie Oliver or whatever equivalent. It's Mrs. Rundle's Domestic Cookery. Yeah. But he also publishes textbooks, Navy lists, and the novels of Jane Austen. And although Murray is a Tory, and Byron is very suspicious of Tories, they actually get on tremendously well. They have a very creative editorial relationship. And Byron is happy that
他可以依赖默里。但他并没有抱太大期望。他保持着那种对整个写作追求的傲慢的蔑视态度，并决定，好吧，也许我会去追求政治生涯。到1812年初，他开始成为辉格党大沙龙中的一个特色人物。所以辉格党人，他们非常非常贵族化。他们是那种“开明”的贵族，不是吗？是的。所以权力的中心实际上是这些由辉格党社会的名媛经营的沙龙，其中最令人生畏的是荷兰庄园。
he can rely on Murray. But he doesn't expect too much of it. And he retains this kind of lordly tone of contempt towards the whole pursuit of scribbling and decides, well, perhaps I'll go for a political career. And by early 1812, he is starting to become a feature in the great Whig salons. So the Whigs, they're very, very aristocratic. They're kind of bien pensant aristocrats, aren't they? Yeah. So the centre of power really are these salons that are rung by the Grand Dame of Whig society, of which the most formidable is Holland House.
名字起得真好。对于一群高尚的亲法派来说，名字非常贴切。所以荷兰勋爵和夫人。荷兰勋爵像拜伦一样，是拿破仑的崇拜者，在那里有他的半身像，被托利党人视为邪恶的、颠覆性的人物。而荷兰夫人，他的妻子，她是牙买加种植园主的女儿，在第一任丈夫与她离婚两天后就嫁给了荷兰勋爵。所以这给了他们一种浮华的、放荡和丑闻的光环。
Splendidly named. Very aptly named for a group of high-minded Francophiles. So Lord and Lady Holland. Lord Holland is like Byron, a big admirer of Napoleon, has busts of him up there, and is seen by Tories as the sinister figure, sinister subversive figure. And Lady Holland, his wife, she is the daughter of a Jamaican planter and had married Lord Holland two days after her first husband had divorced her. And so that gives to them a kind of flamboyant aura of raffishness and scandal.
这非常拜伦式，除了荷兰庄园里非常冷，因为……她不开暖气。不同意供暖。她不开暖气。不喜欢那样。疯狂。这真是软弱的行为。但她崇拜拜伦。
And it's all very Byronic, except for the fact it's incredibly cold in Holland House because... She doesn't turn the heating on. Doesn't agree with heating. She doesn't turn the heating on. Doesn't like that. Mad. That's such weak behaviour. But she adores Byron.
她基本上是第一个，但不是最后一个，会迷恋他的中年女士。她一直崇拜他。他是一个如此可爱的人。我记得他坐在那里，光照在他身上，看起来如此美丽。我敢打赌，如果她看到他在雅典工作时的样子，她就不会这么说了。嗯，也许吧，因为，你知道，他们是辉格党人。他们确实有复杂的进步观点。是的。所以拜伦想，好吧，你知道，也许我的未来是作为一名辉格党政治家。所以
And she basically is the first, but not the last, middle-aged lady who will become obsessed by him. And she always adored him. He was such a lovable person. I remember him sitting there with that light upon him, looking so beautiful. I bet she wouldn't say that if she'd seen him at work in Athens. Well, maybe, because, you know, they are Whigs. They do have sophisticated progressive opinions. Yeah. And so Byron thinks, well, you know, maybe my future is as a Whig politician. And so on the
1812年2月27日，他在上议院发表了处女演讲，他反对托利党的一项将破坏机械织机定为死罪的措施。所以我们正处于工业革命的全盛时期。所以卢德分子，实际上，砸碎机器以试图保护工作岗位。是的。拜伦正在代表诺丁汉失业的织袜工发言。你知道，他们向他表达了诉求。所以他正在代表他们发言。他的演讲非常有力量。非常热情。非常感人，但这并不是真正的政治家演讲。这是诗人的演讲。即使拜伦在假装蔑视文学事业，实际上他也在关注即将出版的《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》，该书定于他发表演讲两周后出版。
27th of February, 1812, he gives his maiden speech in the House of Lords and he is opposing a Tory measure to make the breaking of mechanized looms a capital offence. So we're in the kind of, you know, the heyday of the industrial revolution. So Luddites, effectively, smashing up machines to try and protect jobs. Yeah. And Byron is speaking on behalf of the unemployed stocking weavers of Nottingham. You know, they've made representations to him. And so he's speaking up on their behalf. And his speech is very powerful. It's very passionate. It's very moving, but it's not really a politician's speech. It's a poet's speech. And Byron, even as he is affecting to despise a literary career, actually he has an eye on the forthcoming publication of Charles Harold's Pilgrimage, which is due to come out two weeks after he gives the
他说，我基本上是把它当作广告，这非常现代。没错。是的。我的意思是，你知道，他对促销机会非常非常警觉。他是摄政时期政治界的娜丁·多里斯，汤姆。所以在他发表处女演讲两周后，3月3日，约翰·默里出版了《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》，并在三天内售罄。人群开始围攻书店，先是在伦敦，然后是全国各地。正如拜伦著名地所说，他一觉醒来发现自己出名了。基本上，对于席卷伦敦的拜伦热，只有一个词。这个词将在几年后由一位具有数学倾向，但有某种压抑的浪漫渴望的年轻女性创造出来。一位最终会梦想拯救拜伦的女继承人，名叫安娜贝拉·米尔班克。
speech. He says, I'm basically doing it as an advertisement for it, which is incredibly modern. Right. Yeah. I mean, you know, he's very, very alert to opportunities for promotion. He's the Nadine Doris, Tom, of regency politics. So two weeks after he's given his maiden speech, on the 3rd of March, John Murray publishes Child Harold's Pilgrimage and it sells out within three days. Crowds start mobbing booksellers first in London, then across the entire country. Byron, as he famously says, awakes to find himself famous. And basically there's only one word for the obsession with Byron that sweeps London. And it's a word that will be coined a few years later by a young woman of mathematical inclinations, but kind of suppressed romantic yearnings. An heiress who in due course will come to dream of saving Byron by the name of Annabella Milbank.
而她创造的词，多米尼克，是“拜伦狂热”。拜伦狂热。嗯，关于拜伦狂热，汤姆，令人惊奇的是，即使在拜伦狂热开始时，拜伦职业生涯中一些最丑闻、最丰富多彩和最肮脏的事件还没有到来，不是吗？不可思议的故事。不可思议的故事。我的意思是，我们有一些非凡的事情要来。如果你想马上听到那些故事，你知道你必须做什么。我的意思是，我们已经说了这么多次了，
And the word she coins, Dominic, is Byromania. Byromania. Well, and the amazing thing about Byromania, Tom, is that even as Byromania kicks in, some of the most scandalous, colourful and sordid incidents in Byron's career are yet to come, aren't they? Unbelievable story. Unbelievable story. I mean, we've got some extraordinary stuff coming. If you want to hear those stories right away, you know what you have to do. I mean, we've got some extraordinary stuff coming. If you want to hear those stories right away, you know what you have to do. I mean, we've said this so many times,
你一定听腻了。去therestishistory.com，注册“历史的其余部分”俱乐部，各种各样的款待和福利。你也可以马上听到那些剧集。如果没有，恐怕你只能等到周一才能看到这个强大系列的第三集。在那之前，请不要做任何拜伦勋爵不会做的事情。带着这个重磅炸弹，非常感谢你，汤姆。我们下次再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
you must be sick of it. Go to therestishistory.com, sign up to the Rest is History Club, all kinds of treats and benefits. And you also get to hear those episodes straight away. If not, I'm afraid you will just have to wait until Monday for episode three in this mighty series. Until then, please don't do anything that Lord Byron wouldn't do. And on that bombshell, thank you very much, Tom. We'll see you all next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们共同主持《娱乐余波》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想收听无广告内容、获取额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。